here comes trevor bauer making his
second start at dodger stadium in a
dodger uniform he was fantastic the
first time around giving up just an
infield single against the colorado
rockies a little more than a week ago
well in the outing on sunday in san
diego trevor bauer in no decision but
just the one run on cronenworth's homer
over six innings and opponents hitting
114 against and that's second best in
baseball fernando last night of course
had a nice night couple home runs his
third and fourth of the season and this
one is in the air to deep left field
back goes aj pollock he is at the wall
and fernando has left the building again
fernando tatis jr with two last night
leads off game three tonight with
another home run
you cannot do it any better than he is
doing it right now
talk about a jump start right out of the
gate hanging breaking ball out of the
hand of bauer
and you know with the way the ball has
been traveling a lot of hard hit balls
to the warning track pollock runs out of
room
fernando stay hot
oh he's covering one eye one eye covered
yeah
blake snell who's looking for his first
win as a padre faced the dodgers on
sunday gave up the taylor home run that
was it over five innings and a no
decision so one out in the first inning
brings up corey seeger and he ties him
up with strike three fastball up and in
first strikeout for blake snell there's
the high fastball
he likes to throw that pitch as well we
saw it from bauer
snell says i can do that as well
jerickson pro far switch hitter batting
left-handed myers on second and this one
is lined to center field it'll get in
myers being waved around dj peters up
and throwing in the throw up the line
and the padres take a two-nothing lead
jurickson profile with an rbi single and
san diego on top two nothing
another good at bat by
a padre hitter this time it's jerickson
profar
he gets out the video game controller as
he stands on first base but a fast ball
away profar just serves this ball in
center and the double pump by dj peters
i think cost him on this play ball's
right in front of him he catches it
cleanly
pats that glove twice
i think that ended up costing him
as will myers is able to score rbi
chance for max muncie who drove in the
dodgers only run last night with a first
inning single
fly ball out towards deep right center
field grisham going back and gresham
makes the catch against the wall
spins and fires back in trent grisham
makes the grab and robs max muncie at
the wall
there's gold out there he's on the
shortstop side
in center field
two-thirds of the earth is covered by
water
the other third is covered by that man
trent grisham
grisham up against the fence makes the
play
it would not have been a home run for
max muncie but it was hit really well
out to deep center field and grisham
tracked it down and made the catch he's
golden out there tatisse and grisham and
machado against trevor bauer he swings
through a fastball and bau wins the
second match up that's his fourth
strikeout of the game and the first down
to the third swung on and missed strike
three second time he has been struck out
five strikeouts for power back to back
base hits for the top two hitters in the
dodgers order with two outs and we'll
give justin turner a chance ace hit into
left field three hits in a row after two
out in the score is bet sliding safely
into third is seeger the dodgers are on
the board the padres lead is two to one
something they did so well
postseason play in particular the world
series two outs dodgers collectively hit
324.
so they get on the board that's one of
the feel-good moments
to the time run at third the go-ahead
running scoring position crowd has been
very energetic tonight looking for
something to explode over here it's a
bouncer
[Applause]
and the game is tied at two nothing was
headed foul yes it was oh my god
what are you doing
and snell for whatever reason picked it
up in fair ground had no play so an
infield single for noisy in a 2-2 game
nine in a row retired by trevor power
one out in the top of the fifth
ferratini left hand back three straight
curveballs to carratini to strike him
out and his entire ten in a row curve
ball gets him
trevor's got a new celebration at least
for tonight tonight after strikeouts
looks like he's putting a sword away wow
i love it and with two outs all of a
sudden runners on second and third swung
on in mass ran the slider in on him and
he comes up with his seventh strike out
of the night and a huge one to strand
two men in scoring position we'll see
what kind of celebration either one of
them has depending on which one is
successful in this bat there's a fly
ball headed towards deep left center
field back goes dj peters at the wall
nanda's left the building again
second home run of the night for
fernando tatis junior two last night two
tonight one eye two eyes doesn't matter
this kid is special excuse me as i step
stutter around third base on the home
run trot a little bauer shimmy there at
the end oh yeah the bowers
strut there it is there it is oh yeah
the dodgers and the padres are at it
again now you've got the bases loaded
with one out and mookie bets coming up
this
[Applause]
into the spotlight tim hill on to face
him seeger fans hit into right center
field taylor scores
babies on his way home arriving at third
is smookie dents and the dodgers have
taken a 5-3 lead
the dodgers take the lead a two-run
single from seeger it's 5-3
and they are loaded with one out for you
guessed it fernando tatis jr yanks it
coming from third base will be connor
worth he's in and it's a one-run ball
game five four dodgers here in the
seventh wow that was a wild pitch of
wild pitches right there two and two to
tatis
[Applause]
90 feet away go ahead run in scoring
position chance in to face jurickson
profile
line drive one hop rios has it runs to
the bag beats pro far and the inning is
over no runs one hit
two left so mateo at second with one
down and now fernando doesn't need to
find a gap to tie the game bouncing ball
to short muncie throws tatissa henley
jansen looking for a four out save he's
got
three of those four outs tren grisham
stands in and missed strike three
the dodgers hang on and beat the padres
five to four